so do you want to have some conscious
embodiment or do you just want to have
the same old bloody unconscious
embodiment that your dad had and his dad
before him
and that your culture gave you and
you're supposed to have as a
working-class british bloke or whatever
the hell you are out there
like like that's you could just be
completely unconscious with that or you
can say you know what i
choose something different and i'm a
believer of any embodied practice if
people
want to do yoga or dance or martial arts
different people like different things
great
get in your body start to feel again
stop
thinking that working over porn and
reading books is going to cut it
like get into a dojo go do yoga do
something that you get into your body
again
and reclaim that humanity
what does embodiment actually mean
guys that every single individual is
different answers one
you know your body is a part of you it's
not just
like a pen something it's a part of who
you are
as a person your body the subjective
view of the body so the body as an
aspect of our being is an aspect of who
we are as people
there's a reason if people lose an arm
they get more upset than if they lose a
pen because it's part of them
um another term for embodiment would be
the umbrella
the umbrella term for all the body-mind
arts so i've done
martial arts yoga meditation conscious
dance body therapy
improv bodywork all these things have
something in common they relate to the
body
for awareness and the body is part of
who we are um so even though they look
very different they have this thing in
common so we need a sort of terminology
for that you could say body mind arts
you could say somatic arts
embodiment is the word i tend to use so
that would be
another definition third definition
could be a form of intelligence and we
could drill down into exactly
what the skill sets are within that so
how's that for an opener
nice man i like it considering
embodiment to me
is a if you ask me to define it i
wouldn't really understand maybe
i embody the role of a parent
i embody the role of a podcaster you
know
um but so it's crossing the barrier
between the mental and the physical
whilst remaining in the body
yeah so the common sense usage is
actually quite close to the technical
usage we say you know
such and such uh embodies leadership we
understand that
there's only so much you can learn from
a book if someone said to you
you know i've read chris i've read a lot
of books on kissing i'm an amazing lover
you know i've looked at a lot of
websites on how to drive a car do you
want to lift newcastle you might say
well hang on
that's one way of knowing that's knowing
about
something right so i've been listening
to some of your podcasts to prep for
this it tends to be the western
philosophical tradition is to think
about or to know about or to learn about
and that's useful like it's useful for
me to know the capital of france is
paris
but that's quite different from the
embodied knowledge of paris it's quite
different from
you know having your coffee in paris and
there's a certain kind of light that
comes up in the morning and
being aware of that or the french way of
being god forbid
uh or um you know that that manner of
frenchness
so this is a different kind of of
knowledge and
requires a different kind of learning so
you know i'm at school i read every book
in the library
i was in sixth forms high school for
american listeners
i literally speed read every book in
that library
and yet i was suicidal drug addicted
miserable
failing at my first intimate
relationships and everyone was telling
me i was really clever they said you've
got
high iq you know you're very clever guy
and i said if i'm so clever
why am i so miserable what is education
how has education failed me well the
goal
the goal of education especially at that
age isn't to make you happy
yeah i mean there's a sort of frame that
you can say it's social conformity
but even if it were just knowledge the
sort of main view of that is you learn
about things you
acquire knowledge and it's you know
wikipedia hasn't solved all the world's
problems right we've got
on this phone there's more knowledge
than most human beings had in your
alexander's library or whatever right so
there's all that information there but
is that the same as wisdom
and if i want to change if i want to
grow as a person
i'm going to at the very least have to
acquire skills like kissing and driving
or maybe even a deeper level change who
i am as a person
and while you can take a drug or go on a
weekend workshop
what really works there is actually
embodying something different and that
takes practice over time
i've been thinking a lot this year about
the
world of self-development
self-improvement
and i think a lot of the challenges that
we're coming up against
are given very cerebral answers people
try and think themselves out this is a
a post-modern posting post-enlightenment
scientific utilitarian um
very transactional kind of environment
that we're living in
and that has some
wonderful advantages unlike the greeks
who
thought that bloodletting was a great
way to get rid of
diseases or i think aristotle believed
that the brain
only existed to get heat out of the body
you know we've made
the scientific revolution has given us
some wonderful insights
and drilling down into the world of
personal development self-development a
lot of the guests that i've had on this
show
they do by its very nature we can only
ever show someone or tell someone what
to do we can't do it for them
and i suppose that the um
that bifurcation in
distributing what people can do versus
them actually enacting it embodying it
and doing it
is that are we getting into some part of
the framework that you look at here by
seeing that distinction
yeah so the distinction between knowing
about and knowing to do and knowing to
be
i mean if we look at the greeks they had
the word soma
which meant the body and its wholeness
the embodied body
and they had sarks which meant kind of a
hunk of meat and that's generally how
the body is viewed as a hunk of meat
even in a gym where you're trying to get
fit
the body is an object which is a
fundamentally dehumanizing position
uh you know the greeks also had
philosophy in the gym the gymnasium
wasn't a place just to lift weights it
was also a place for emotional
psychological lifting
and an embodied perspective is one which
recognizes that these things are
deeply intertwined you know we say
academic meaning
irrelevant meaning cognitive you know my
friend is an academic
god love him you know i tried to tell
him my embodiment he was like well my
body just gets me from one lecture to
another
and i was like dude there's real
consequences to that you know in his
case it's health consequences emotional
consequences
and there's a human consequence for uh
being hyper cerebral
uh being you know it's not sort of
cognocentric you're sometimes here
there's a slightly pretentious way of
just saying that thought is what matters
and actually our embodied life our
embodied being are
you know like everything like we're
building a relationship right you're
someone i reached out to i thought he
seems like a cool guy let's get to know
each other now even though we're doing
that virtually
the felt sense of each other is the key
thing it's like is this a man i can push
on and trust
is this someone who's going to be fun to
have a laugh with is this someone who's
got backbone and spine
there's a reason we use that kind of
language when we describe character
and let's say i'm in the business world
doing business leadership training which
i've done quite a lot of
they'll be very good at telling you what
a leader should have and saying you know
i've done my mba you know leadership be
empathic and
charismatic and then you'll say well how
do you develop that
right or you're the philosophers they'll
say about man should have these virtues
well jesus said you know you love thy
neighbor and i'm always thought was kind
of lacking on the detail chris
i've always thought it was kind of
lacking on the method so and this is
where i think some of the asian arts
were uh
ahead of the western knowledge in a way
they had a praxis they had a way of
developing oneself
and if someone's stressed or wants to be
a better leader you know someone's
listening to this and they're
lonely because they're covered or you
know they're isolated or someone's
listening to this and they're just
being driven nuts by their boss they
don't really need more information they
need a practice they need to
shift their way of being i think
you're very right the fact that we
believe that more knowledge is the
answer
as opposed to increasing our compliance
to the knowledge that we already have
every personal trainer or anyone that's
ever been to the gym
knows that it's not really that much
about what diet or what training plan
you follow versus whether you follow it
consistently over a long enough period
of time if you do
anything long enough you'll get good at
it now the hope is that
the thing that you do for long enough to
get good at it isn't drugs
or isn't cheating on your partner or
whatever it might be um just just to
book end something you mentioned there
you talked about the greeks and about
how the gymnasium
was this place that was not only one of
physical being but of mental being as
well
did you know that plato's real name
wasn't plato
what was his real name keith no
thankfully not there was also there was
no keith spawn in the uk in 2018 that's
another they're a dying breed
um aristocles it was claimed that
plato's real name was aristocles and
that plato
was a nickname that translates to
roughly the broad
derived either from the width of his
shoulders the results of training
for wrestling or the breadth of his
style or from the size of his forehead
so hopefully it's from the broadness of
his shoulders not the size of his
forehead
yeah and you know this is throughout
history people have talked about how you
know
what george washington's sadder horse
you know nelson mandela was a boxer
there's
there's not the only one but uh this has
been lost somewhat if we look at our
kind of current
uh crop of politicians or corporate
trainers and you mentioned practice
like we're all practicing something like
everyone out there listening to this
maybe you've got you know youtube on
your phone where you're taking a [ __ ]
maybe you're walking down the street
maybe uh you know you've got it on in
the car
you're practicing a way of being like i
interview people from my podcast and you
see their way of being all the time
someone as soon as someone comes on some
people are like right
in your room right in your face other
people are like oh
let me examine this some people are wide
and they're like big you know like
americans can be it's a cultural
embodiment you know like hey
and other people you know you had
douglas murray on i was like you know
douglas has his particular douglas-ness
doesn't he
and it's it's it's very particular it's
a flavor
and there's a way and that is great for
some things
and a rubbish for others so my
general approach to personal growth
whether it's business yogi's life
coaches whoever i'm working with
is awareness ranging choice so first
thing is we need to know what we're
doing
what's the default right like most
people don't know which way they cross
their arms but then you try it both ways
you know and you go ah okay that's
really uncomfortable oh done with your
fingers yeah
so you this is like your personality
there's you could you could lean
forwards lean back and people could try
this go on the
balls of their feet and then on the
heels you know it's like go
up yeah some people they're kind of all
up here aren't they and they were very
anxious or they're like
dude like totally spicy like in northern
california or
you know my family are like irish potato
people they right down here in the earth
you know and you see this in different
parts of england you know something's
more grounded like northern tends to be
a bit more grounded and not himself a
bit more up here
so there's cultural fact it's not
everyone because there's individual
factors too there's situational factors
there's relational factors these are all
going on in embodiment
so i don't know if you're like this all
the time this is the first time i've
seen you right
so i or if you just like this when you
do interviews so there's all these
different
aspects of embodiment but if we bring
some awareness to that
maybe we can try something different the
first
place that anyone has to go with any
type of change presumably
is cultivating a sense of awareness of
what they're doing at the moment
know thyself nothing new
where do we go next choice so this is
the difference with mindfulness and
embodiment mindfulness is like be aware
of your state and it's like oh i'm
really angry
right and it's like well hang on a
minute i've got a meeting with my staff
this is a real example
absolutely pissed off with something
really angry and then it was like well
i don't want to bring that to my team
that's not going to be a helpful state
to bring to my team
so then then we become the philosophy
won't help you here but the physiology
will
so here we then have the physiological
shift so maybe it's
you know i put my feet on the ground ah
come back in my chair and soften my jaw
i let my peripheral vision open up
i take a deep belly breath and you know
people listening can try this if they
want you know
you can do this with your eyes open
driving a car
okay tell me again what was it you were
saying chris
so that ability to shift state is so key
and you know you don't want to be that
guy on the high street shower and say
i'm not angry
he doesn't even know he's angry but if
he did know he's angry he'd still have a
second thing to do which would be to
shift it if he wanted
or he could express it which is another
skill that's another
embodied skill a lot of my fellow
english men lack is the ability to
express themselves
you know like i lived in brazil for a
while in the slums of brazil working
there and
i got back and i was just more fluid and
relaxed my mom was like
where did you get those hips you know it
was like i learned this
i lived above the nightclub for six
months in brazil
did nothing but [ __ ] fight and dance
for six months and i came back and it
was like
there was a different embodiment because
i'd been you know you know this like you
got holiday for a week even you can
start to soak up the embodiment or
you go down to london from newcastle
it's a different vibe right yeah very
much so very very much so
so we've got awareness to begin with we
need to know that we
are x and i'm going to guess that this
could be
uh macro or micro that we are
angry in the moment or that we are
perhaps unhappy or frustrated over time
state and trait so awareness of state is
easy you can feel it that's mindfulness
awareness of trait is invisible it's
like the taste of your own mouth
you have to have it pointed out or you
have to do some kind of comparison to
feel the difference
so the guy who's always angry doesn't
feel angry he's
just it's like comfortable underpants
he's you know you've gotten used to it
you know
i don't know i'm not even wearing
anything i haven't worn any for ages but
it's like
you're used to that embodiment so you
have to step out of it to feel it
it might not it might only be by
stepping out there and you're going [ __ ]
i'm spending a lot i'm angry most of the
time i didn't even realize
everybody else can see it but he can't
state is much
easier it's like being tired or being
energized or
you know like i know it's like a little
bit nervous for this interview not a lot
but a little bit
okay might want to slow down a little
bit mark so if i can notice my stay
i can change it yeah
i'm gonna guess that
knowledge or the learning is going to
help us more moving from step one to
step two rather than just being step one
step one of the awareness of either our
state or trait
is simply cultivating a mindfulness of
what is happening
either in that moment or what has
changed over time but moving on to step
two which is
choice and choice but you don't
necessarily know
you mentioned the man that is angry even
if he becomes aware of his anger
needs to learn or needs to have a
particular process that he can follow in
order to
enact that anger to release that anger
to deal with that anger to do whatever
so i guess that you do require some
knowledge in the choice
section yeah i'm not anti-knowledge i
love what the west brings in terms of
science and the renaissance i love
the fact that we can dissect things and
you know i'm a geek for this stuff
like i'll look at practices and i'll say
okay you could try
you you're kind of i'm coaching this
like russian business guy today and it's
like he's kind of a bit stiff you know
and i'm like okay you could try
conscious dance you could try improv
comedy
you know i could just give you a little
exercise to do at home that just takes
two minutes because you're a busy guy
you know this is where we get geeky and
this is where a bit of expert knowledge
can come in to know how to shift
but people are also pretty intuitive
about this stuff like
you know i could take something to say
let's say there's a young woman who's
lost her confidence this happens to a
lot of girls in teenage years their
embodiment kind of folds over they get
these kind of round shoulders they lose
that natural confidence kids have
now someone like that they know what
it's like to be confident because
they've
seen it and at some point in their life
they've done it
even if they only do it one day in a
hundred so
actually people know you know like if i
say to a little kid which direction is
happy
sounds like a weird question but the i
asked that to a seven-year-old they
jumped up in the air
right like in which direction is angry
is it tight or is it relaxed well most
people would go okay it's
forwards and tight yeah like people can
figure this stuff out
i mean i have maps for it and i you know
as i said i geek out about it but um
it's uh it's our human inheritance
really to know this stuff
so we've got choice and what's heard
that's it
there's awareness there's awareness
range and choice so range means you can
actually have some options that's kind
of the middle ground
sometimes i say awareness acceptance and
choice
so this is the paradox of change that we
need to know how we are and then say
okay that is how i am and right now i'm
scared well right now i'm angry
saying yes to that you know i was
listening to your man on who is stoic
guy you know being able to accept things
a really important skill
and then moving to do i want to change
something can i change something am i
going to take the time to develop
myself and maybe that's a small practice
like
walking a little bit more um you know
you see some people they're walking
their arms
vapid they take small steps you know
their practice could be walking to work
every morning
with just a little bit more push from
the back foot swinging the arms just a
little bit more
it's getting it like every day for 10
minutes you know and then we have the
relational side
okay so we have awareness and choice for
self but then what about other people
before we get on to that um sure there
may be
people who are naturally or trained to
be more utilitarian
very pragmatic and they will say well
that's all well and good mark tell me to
walk a little bit more off my heels and
stand up straight with my shoulders back
like jordan peterson
but that's that's just a physical
movement that's me just
drilling you're telling me to walk a
particular way
that doesn't change anything about me
other than my gait
yeah so the first thing i'd say is don't
believe a word i say okay
first thing i'd say is try these things
i mean i could be some cult leader lying
to you for my own you know financial
benefit or something right
so um don't believe me like that would
be nice
who the hell am i i'm just some guy from
the internet so i would say try
it you know for example i get some guy
to do star jumps jumping jacks they call
him in america and say tell me you're
sad
it's just impossible right it's like
like if you get someone to do burpees
and no one's happy if you make them do
burpees no one's happy if you make them
do
star jumps oh here's another one
someone's tired and i say right well you
could do chest breathing for three
breaths
right
okay do you feel more or less tired
percent of people saying i feel more
awake i feel less tired
right don't believe me like test this
stuff you know and if you
if you have enough trust after a few of
these little tests to do a bigger test
like
taking up tango dancing or taking up
karate or you know taking out whatever
south
dancing whatever it is and then see how
it changes your life
and like that's my philosophy like you
know how it's not a religion
yeah i uh really enjoyed this insight i
got from derek sivers earlier on this
year
founder of cd baby really really
insightful guy
and he uh he talked about
most books are spending their time
convincing you that the author's word is
worth trusting
the vast majority of books are either
context
or justification and
what's what's really interesting about
that and it's an insight that i've never
heard i've
rift quite a lot this year on a lot of
books a blog post that should have been
a tweet
expanded out into 200 pages
but what derek hit upon that i really
really enjoyed is that
most books have a one particular key
insight
but the problem is that you don't trust
the author enough to believe it
so they have to they have to give you
all of these different examples
like if your best friend who's last
five pieces of advice for you about
relationships or the horse that you
should pick or whether you should move
house or that job or whatever
if they just gave you gold advice and
they came up and said
well mate here's the central the central
thrust of and just said the
bottom line impact of a particular book
you'd be like yeah
cool but when it's a stranger that's not
the case
the authority and trust right so
precisely another embodied phenomena as
well
i mean there's a reason you know british
airways when they say you know tonight
today we'll be flying at ten thousand
feet and
blah blah blah and your mother would
probably find me attractive you know
there's a there's a
there's a embodiment to the british
airways voice for example
now if they were like hello welcome to
british airways uh
we're going to malaga i hope it's going
to be fine i mean just the anxiety you'd
hear that fight or flight response and
you wouldn't trust that guy so
i mean one's embodiment of this two
factors warmth and power
so one one factor is like is this person
authoritatively competent
now we can base that in past experience
like you know i've listened to your
podcast so i know you're a competent
interviewer for example right i can base
that on that experience
however if i didn't i would get that
sensed from the first three seconds of
this interview
because you're relaxed you're like i
know what i'm doing you know this is
home base for me welcome to my
home you know but the podcast i do this
all the time you know it's episode
whatever it is 250. yeah
and then there's warmth right but if you
just did power
you'd be like okay mark [ __ ] you i'm in
charge i know what's going on
you know like like i'm the boss here and
then i'd be like oh i'm feeling
uncomfortable
i don't i don't feel very relaxed so you
know with children with horses with
human beings generally like this is just
what we need to convey
and these are embodied capabilities cool
so we've looked at the individual
and then relation relational life's
about relationship right if we're just
on our own in a cave it's not a very
satisfying life for most people
so it's the same thing this is the
embodiment skill set and what
intelligence i sometimes call it um
awareness and choice then we have self
and others so other we have awareness of
other
and that is state and pattern same thing
okay state and trait
so it's can i look at someone and go
you're all right like i was talking to
my colleague yesterday and i just went
are you okay and she went actually my
mom's in hospital and my housemates hate
me
and it's like she just needed to listen
you know 10 minutes of me listening to
her before we could get with the
business meeting it was fine and i
didn't mind at
all but had i not caught just in my gut
in my own
empathy is embodied without embodiment
you're psychopathic
right like if you're not feeling and we
all have this experience maybe
you know on the tube or walking through
a crowded street or when we're stressed
during a rush
we lose empathy because our body
tightens we lose the ability to resonate
you know you've had that experience
right i've just been a bit of a dick and
then afterwards going
i'm sorry i was stressed i shouldn't
have said that and you'd lost empathy in
that moment
yeah so when we're relaxed and we're
open and we're centering ourselves we've
done
the stuff we just talked about we've got
some chance of resonating with other
people in this case
realizing my reasoning my colleague
wasn't very well and you needed a bit of
listening to
so that's the listening side the empathy
and then and then there's body
reading right where we can look at
different patterns and that's always a
guess and it's to be approached with
humility but
in a way it's common sense you know
you're walking down the street someone's
there you go ah this doesn't feel good
right you get either in your own body or
you see something then that you're
looking around they've got a certain
muscle tone they've got a certain
tension in their body their breathing's
a certain way and you go
maybe best cross the road yeah so it's
like you know i
worked in war zones for years and i got
quite attuned to this i spent a lot of
time watching people
who i didn't really speak their language
or i was just learning their language
like brazil east africa middle east
afghanistan
and i go is this safe so i was quite
motivated to figure out
whether they were shouting because that
was just their culture and like you know
like in the mediterranean school shout
or was it that they were angry and this
could be a dangerous situation
and the other thing is just touching a
lot of bodies if you touch a lot of
bodies
you start to get a different felt sense
then so i was traveling around the world
doing martial arts
um and after touching several thousand
bodies like in in quite intimate ways in
some ways
you start to get a bit of a better felt
sense of people than the average person
um so that's that's the sort of third of
the four
capabilities which is awareness of other
people
i did for a long time when i was a kid i
did laugha kung fu which is a southern
style of kung fu very popular
yeah and i did that to brown sash and a
big part of that
is sticking hands yes so with that
anyone who doesn't know what that is it
looks a little bit like a dance
you have your wrists on my wrists from
your right on my left my left on your
right
and we yeah we roll we roll our wrists
between each other
and what you're waiting for as you're
moving forward the other person will
move backwards and as they move towards
you you'll move backwards and what
you're waiting for is a break
if that person breaks contact with your
wrists and you're flowing backwards and
forwards left and right in circles and
then you'll reverse the circles
and you're waiting for a break and at
that break is an opening at which you
can then
move into that person but if you move
into them when they're still touching
you
they know you're moving and they can
reverse that particular move and then
you'll end up being struck
so that insight incredibly intimate you
use the word intimate there which is one
that
comes sort of quite heavily loaded but
it's really correct you know that was
some of the most intimate understandings
that i got of how other people's bodies
worked
and really you know sort of being honest
other than
proper body work that i've had done to
me or that i've said oh hey mate like
you're back to in like give me
i'll give you a hand other than that or
you know
much more intimate sort of passionate
relationship stuff
you don't i had i know i've done that my
understanding my
genuine felt understanding of what other
people's bodies
are and how they move would be
significantly lower and i know that
doing laughter kung fu
is an outlier you know it's not like you
you well it's a great sensitivity
practice it doesn't surprise me you've
done martial arts by the way
you can feel that in a person you know
it's it's a way when someone carries
themselves even years afterwards when
they've had that character training
and some you know some practices have
that sensitivity sometimes people learn
a physical skill and it never really
transfers into their life you know
what like any any particular physical
skills that you see
in people that don't tend to translate
across much yeah
so i mean everything but let's take
let's say you spend let's take a popular
practice yoga
so people could get very good at being
calm in yoga
and then walk out of yoga pick up their
phone go on facebook and immediately
start a flame war
now they've got had a little bit of a
holiday from their life in yoga
and they've had a bit of calming down
which is you know it's good for all of
us so
good luck to you if that's what you want
to do but they haven't really learned
any skills
they haven't really transferred any
skills across from yoga
um into their life which is kind of a
pity and there's these ways i you know
point out for my yoga students about how
to
increase the transfer or else you know
particularly
it's a particular container say in
aikido school or a yoga school
it's got its own clothes its own ritual
its own words you know the
stay with the phone example there's no
mobile phones right so i spend about an
hour a day on my mobile phone at least
i'd say
so i might have let's say i've learned a
breathing exercise like belly breathing
diaphragmatic breathing
well why don't you try that with your
phone and if that's too easy
get your email on your phone and then
see if you're still breathing
right we can actually train that as a
transferable skill
so that's one of the things i do with
students we'll start with like let's say
we're
trading the stress response so we'll
we'll start with throwing a tissue at
them throwing a kleenex at them
and they they flinch all right i mean it
actually even works online you want to
try
okay what did you do in your body when i
threw that out of the camera yeah you
want to move backwards you want to jerk
backwards
did you move backwards yes or no uh a
little bit yeah
yeah a little bit and you tensed up
probably a little bit too right yeah
and your breathing changed a little bit
a little short sharp breath in
okay great so good noticing you have
higher body awareness than a lot of the
beginning
that would already indicate to me you
had some real practice behind you
already
and then you would get with building
your awareness of that fight flight
response
then we could give you a technique to
work with it it could be something as
simple as
um uh can i offer you one now chris is
that right like a little bit
away man yeah your eyes are quite narrow
it may be you're just looking at the
camera it may just be today i don't know
but
try opening up your vision so you can
see
all around the computer not just the
computer stuff in your jaw a little bit
we call this the russian smile in russia
say ah
okay what happened that time when i
threw the tissue nothing not a whole lot
less right so we actually just trained
you to reduce your
flight response now throwing tissues out
he's completely pointless
but what we could do and i won't do this
online because it's a bit personal
we could train to take this into a
coaching environment and we could use a
situation like a piece of criticism or
something stressful maybe your
girlfriend criticizes you or your mum or
your boss
and we could then train that to a again
notice the response
and b to then reduce that response so
this is the reducing the fight flight
response because it's usually not
helpful
unless you know you've got a heavy rock
to lift or say it doesn't really help
for our social interaction
um or we could work with expressing it
right that'd be a whole other set of
practices
cool just to close that open loop that
we've got there will be a lot of people
listening uh there'll be a lot of people
listening who do yoga
and they're thinking oh [ __ ] l marx
rumbled me there um i i do
really enjoy my practice i do feel very
mindful very embodied
very centered when i'm doing my yoga and
yet
you're right i i really struggle in x
situation
in traffic when i get out when i have
this that and the other
how can people that are practicing yoga
or similar other practices
transfer that across into their
day-to-day life yeah that is the
question i've spent my life really
looking at that so first of all i'm not
slagging off yoga if anyone's enjoying
yoga if it gives you a break it makes
you less stressed great keep doing it
good for you no problem i like yoga
so i want to say that first of all
because otherwise people think you're
kicking their puppy a little bit you
know
it's um people get very attached to
practices because they help people
um so how to transfer it one notice what
you do 10 minutes before and 10 minutes
after class
so bring in a bit of an awareness to for
example i've seen people be really
abusive to the person at the desk
and like just unpleasant as they go
paying for their cars and then go into
yoga and sit down and start saying oh
yeah and it's like dude not even 10
minutes before you were being mean to
someone
yeah right so we can open up before and
after another thing you can have
reminders so you know iphones are great
for this you just set your phone to go
five times a day when it goes off you do
one yoga breath
one full yoga breath five times a day
okay there's another one
another one micro poses so if you've got
youtube they can look all this up it's
much easier to show than tell but
there's something called embodied yoga
principles
where we explore this on youtube um you
have warrior pose right
how do you get warrior pose into your
life you find the way of doing that on a
small
level so this takes me five ten minutes
to train a yogi in
and we can take a pose they know really
well and we can then take it into
walking
standing and talking and i'll say right
ask me for a cup of tea in warrior pose
right
ask me for a cup of tea in the opposite
of warrior pose how would you walk like
a warrior and they go well you know
move my arms extend from my back leg i'd
look straight ahead
okay great do that and then we've taken
warrior pose
as a sort of bad bit of exercise
into stretching from stretching into
something they can use in conversation
so they can use as a practice walking
down the street so they can use to stand
slightly differently without looking too
weird
now we've made it into transferable
practice there's about 10 other things
but there's um
three for stars there's some nice
takeaways you mentioned that we were at
three out of four yeah so we've done
awareness and choice self and we did
other awareness so it's empathy and body
reading but we didn't do influence so
really it's just based on the other
three
so how do you calm someone
down or wake them up yeah or make them
laugh or turn them on or whatever the
influence you want to have on someone
else is
that's through the body i'll give you an
example of this i was i work in rostral
i was just there now actually and
um i have an interpreter and my
interpreter is very polite i'm
slightly nervous very particular young
lady called julie
and it's quite difficult because i'll
say
and she'll say and it completely changes
the message
so she's actually to her credit she's
learnt my embodiment and she kind of
steps into it and
another example from there when i make a
joke people laugh before she translates
it
why because the embodiment is what's
being conveyed
yeah and this is what we do all the time
like i used to work with kids a lot i
used to work in like you know you know
pgl like outward education and
big groups of kids running around the
woods lots of fun and you know you have
to hold their authority that's a body
thing
and it almost doesn't matter what you
say
you know like my best mate he'll i
haven't seen him in ages he'll see me
once or twice a year back home
and he'll say mark you're the biggest
knob head i've ever made in my life
you're such a wanker
but what his body's saying is i love you
and i missed you
you know this is proper bridge bloke
thing today and that's actually i can
tell that's what his body is saying
because my body relaxes
and it opens it makes sense yeah
this is the fundamental way we influence
people like
you know let's say you're interested in
attraction maybe there's guys women out
there and they you know they're
interested in being more attractive now
you can wear some clothes and get a
haircut and maybe learn some pick up
lines
but if you're not embodying
attractive qualities you won't even be
looked at
you won't even be looked at by women or
men and as soon as you have those it's
just like you can be wearing the
dirty t-shirt with food on it and have
your hair all over the place
and you've all got a mate like that
isn't he annoying you know who kind of
had that naturally he never had to learn
it he had that we call it charisma or
chemistry or
you know chemistry is the body thing if
you and your partner's love life has
gone
and i've worked with gay community a lot
in russia as well so this works with gay
people too but if you you and your
partner your love life has gone a bit
flat
it's you've lost polarity that's
embodied
you know if you're yang and shiz yang or
you're yin and chizzy and that's not
it's not really going to help so can you
actually step into that polarity
step into that where you can influence
them and
um this is an embodied skill line
tremendously useful for any kind of
leaders or influencers
what are the biggest challenges that
people come up against
when trying to improve their influence
they're not basing it on the other stuff
so they try and go straight to the
tricks
and they're not basing it on their own
self-awareness self-regulation and
empathy
um so that you need to sort of they sort
of come to me and say look i'm
fine but everyone else is [ __ ] up
all right maybe let's look at that you
know so um
yeah that's probably the biggest
challenge and just not being in their
bodies i mean if
you know it's like hello i'm norm and
i'm your manager i'm completely in my
head i've got no embodied presence
i'm not feeling anything and i'm trying
to inspire you today
you know just not having any kind of
passion or embodied presence at all that
that's not going to be helpful
i put in my newsletter a couple of weeks
ago that you are the common denominator
in your life
what is what is more likely all of your
relationships end badly let's say or
your boss always seems to like you or
you always seem to be much better with
money than all of your friends
or um you just never get invited out
to parties whatever it might be
wherever you go there you'll be like
you're saying right there you're all
you're always going to
you are the common denominator in your
life and i know it's hard it's hard for
everyone to hear
because it feels so bestowed on you
right like whatever the common threads
are that exist in your life
they manifest in your mind like a curse
that's been thrown down from the heavens
and that's also the way that our
emotions then
manifest them right you like the the
feeling of love
is oxytocin love is an action done in
the body
so but the way that you sense it
the way that it actually manifests when
you try and think and break it down and
you
feel it in your chest and you feel the
warmth that doesn't feel anything like
just a chemical getting released
and the same thing goes for the
situations that occur in your life the
challenges that you face
feel like they've been bestowed upon you
and the successes that you've faced
also for people dealing with imposter
syndrome feel like they've been bestowed
upon you too
yeah i mean personal responsibility is
the first thing i teach all my new
employees it's what i you know we just
took a big team on for the conference we
were talking about earlier and the first
thing i told them is personal
responsibility
it's like you know in embodiment we call
it somatic responsibility it's like no
one made you angry
you made you angry i mean you know you
might say hey he made me angry and
there's a shorthand that's fine but
really it's i did anger in my body this
is from paul linden one of my main
teachers
i did anger in my body when he said x
right like that even if it was an
unconscious choice was a choice
and then actually it's radical to take
responsibility
over yourself and there are that's the
conservative truth right the personal
responsibility
the liberal truth is equally important
to balance which is that there are
conditions
and those conditions might be
intergenerational trauma it might be
poverty it might be whatever the
this you know living in moscow it might
be that you haven't eaten breakfast that
small that morning there's lots of
conditions right
so we have to acknowledge both of those
things the conditions and the
responsibility and
for me embodiment is um a great way to
take responsibility over myself and you
know get out of that victim position
i want to get onto the embodiment
conference in a little bit but before we
do that
can you try and give us some more
common embodiment techniques the
most common ones that you use with your
clients or
that you've been that you've been taught
that you think the broadest
cross-section of people that i know can
probably benefit from some of these
yeah great so i mean we've got state
changes and then we've got how do we
develop ourselves as people there's no
quick wins for the second one
okay like the second one you want to
develop yourself as a person
get a practice start going to karate or
tango or conscious dance
you know do meditation every morning
great that's a long term project
but people often need the quick wins
first so they can have some sort of
state change which is fair enough
so stand differently walk differently
sit differently breathe differently
there you go
that's about it breath do you want to
breathe a bit more in the chest or a bit
more in the belly that will have a
different impact
which do we want well it depends what
you want it for so when everyone talks
about
good breathing or good posture my next
question is well what for
so if i'm trying to go to bed at night
and i want to go to sleep
long smooth out breath yeah
that's camomile tea breath if i want to
wake myself up in the morning espresso
breath
i was in bed this morning i had five
hours sleep i needed to get up to see my
team i was like
okay just one one breath because
sometimes you only got
two or three seconds right i did that
got out of bed
okay simple get up technique whoa i'm
like i'm awake from doing it just now
and then like this evening it's like
what are we at like it's like
oh we've got a few hours yet but
there'll be a oh
that makes me just go to sleep just i
don't do that too much actually being
interviewed
so there's two breaths for you right
away we could say yang and belly and
long out breath versus the in-breath how
do you stand
do you want to take up space or do you
want to be more private more width
or less width more forwards do you want
to be more engaged
like as an interviewer right you could
be more engaged like hey mark tell me
that or you can be more back
evaluating taking your space yeah and we
can go up and down
do you want to be more down we're just
like grounded
solid stubborn we'll fight them on the
beaches
yeah or do you want to be more up here
more like lively and inspired and light
and fun
and well depends when right like maybe
you want to be serious now you're at
work but later on you're relaxing you
know you're having fun with your friends
at the pub you want to be a bit more up
above
so we can use posture walking i've
mentioned
simple ass techniques you're someone
like me who tends to rush
walk a bit slower walk more on the heels
you're someone that lacks confidence
when it's slightly light it doesn't have
to be monty python
just a slightly longer stride push from
your back foot a little bit more
yeah look up you know the jordan
peterson thing about you know stand up
tall
it's not wrong it's just not very
detailed right it's just
it's fine it's just you know i did a
video on what could be added to that
um so what have we done sitting again
you know how do you want to sit
posture breathing movements so these are
basic tools um
and then we can look a bit more
esoterically you know like or a bit more
creatively like um
like right now imagine visualize the
hand of someone
supportive on your back someone from
your past a teacher
maybe a dad or grandparent and lean into
that
yeah you just shifted how was that it's
a nice cue
nice huh so you can have a visualization
like sometimes i'm you know visualize
you're on fire visualize you've got
angel wings visualize your
uh feet or trees i mean you know some
people love visualization but other
people it doesn't work for
um so yeah or we can say okay like i'm
one of my translator julia moscow good
luck which one i'm best friends now
she says um when she wants to be more
confident and kick ass she's
she's kind of like you know she does
sort of her inner mark walsh
and she sort of moves and stands a bit
like me and if i want to be sort of nice
and polite and a bit less offensive
i can be a bit more like julie right
like that's a mode because i'm
quite familiar with julie from years of
standing next to her
i can just it's like channel but there's
nothing weird about it it's just i'm
bringing that person to mind
ah there's a body there's a this quality
with julie eat a particularness
yeah and i it changed as soon as i
started to put that on
but all this stuff is just hacks right
you know in my book
plug there's a whole chapter on on sort
of um
hacks and like little quick wins you can
do
things you can do as you get in a chair
self-coaching
uh it doesn't have to be complicated you
know the iphone that goes off and
reminds you to breathe
that sort of thing but really if i'm
working with people long term it's the
practices
it's what are you really practicing and
yes we can give you shapes to practice
yoga shapes and poses
uh but it's something like you know you
mentioned your your kung fu practice
you know that has stayed with you that
has stayed with you years later because
you put the hours in
and like let's grow up
yes it's nice to go and do somewhere
else or mushrooms yes it's nice to jump
up and down and
you know do a workshop and you know pump
the air and feel good but
unless you're really developing a
practice that stuff's not gonna stick
let's let's get real all the books in
the world won't solve your problems i
can
listen to a thousand podcasts from me or
from you and learn about stoic
philosophy and
listen to douglas murray and all these
great thinkers but unless i develop a
practice i'm not changing
that difference between state and trait
i think is a really good point
to make and again it comes back to the
the transactional nature of what the
self-development world has
has come to and we try
as much as possible to talk about
compliance on this show to try and
remind people that
what you do every day is what you'll end
up becoming
yeah there's a concept which you might
love actually with the martial arts
reference from ethan sipley
my buddy who was in wolf of wall street
big huge hollywood actor
massive guy my name is earl and now he's
lost 300 pounds
and he's got a beard and he wears his
cap on backwards and he dead lifts like
500 pounds he's just to eat a beast
um and he was learning martial arts for
some huge blockbuster that he was in and
the martial arts instructor that he had
gave him a rule which is called no bad
reps
and no bad reps is a really
smart way to remind us
that you're always drilling something
yes the way that myelin sheaths wrap
around the um
neurology neurology yeah neurology of
how the myelin sheaths wrap around in
your brain
isn't that you don't get to choose not
to make a habit you just get to choose
which habit it is that you're making
got this really inquiring together right
now everyone listening to this right now
something is wiring together neurons
that wire together
they're gonna what they're gonna they're
gonna firing together right now they're
wearing together right now
so do you wanna have some conscious
embodiment or do you just want to have
the same old bloody unconscious
embodiment that your dad had and his dad
before him
and that your culture gave you and
you're supposed to have as a
working-class british bloke or whatever
the hell you are out there
like like that's you could just be
completely unconscious with that or you
can say you know what i
choose something different and i'm a
believer of any embodied practice if
people
want to do yoga or dance or martial arts
different people like different things
great
get in your body start to feel again
stop
thinking that wanking over porn and
reading books is going to cut it
like get into a dojo go do yoga do
something that you get into your body
again
and reclaim that humanity what are
some suggestions you've got people think
yeah
yeah
the mark fellow was all right like he
he's that embodiment stuff sounds pretty
good
first off let's say that we're in covid
which we are
um what can or should
what would be a good suggestion for
people to start and then let's say that
we're back into the real world
what are some things perhaps that people
have overlooked that would be a little
bit more left field
okay if they're a complete beginner if
they're pretty cerebral like my academic
friend
any movement practice that involves
feeling whatever's comfortable
and happy and inspires you whether it's
martial arts dance yoga whatever
okay you can do that at home the zoom
classes and all these things now
are actually more available than ever
before so they're you know
getting up from your chair this i don't
like you can see i'm getting answered i
don't like sitting still for an hour you
know i normally move around a lot more
um being in nature being around other
embodied people they're the key factors
but movement
is the first one do some simple things
even if it's just 10 minutes of mindful
breathing a day
a little bit of mindful barefoot walking
on the grass in the park that's what i
do
and then if you feel inspired to a class
if people are listening to this and they
already have a practice
next level examine it is it transferring
question one is your yoga or your cry or
whatever getting off the mat
yeah question two is your practice
chosen from your neurosis and just
making you more and more like how you
are
maybe you actually need a second
practice i did martial arts for ages i
got very disciplined
you know i got that japanese thing that
i needed to get my ass sober and to you
know give me that structure in my body
but then i got a bit uptight and i
needed to go to five rhythms and let it
all hang loose and dance and be free
you know so there's like different
things if you've already got one
practice you might want to look at a
second one
and what's a more left field suggestion
when the world reopens
well let's all have an orgy in newcastle
you know in this in the snow i think i
think it will go clubbing in newcastle
and have a great time
that way guest list available text below
um you mentioned about like
in interpretive dance and and comedy and
all this sort of stuff
you know all of these different
practices might
their horse is for courses but getting
into the body i
i really like that idea i think as well
this year more than ever
i've noticed the lack of variety
in the movements that i've been able to
do you know i haven't been
no one's been going to a nightclub in
2020.
no one's been really spending a ton in
the uk we weren't even
allowed to go out of the house you could
maybe barefoot on the wall on the grass
once per day yeah unless you've got it
unless you've got a garden
people been locked in their houses you
know you live in a city it might be a
fair distance for you to get
to some nature so i think that there's a
good
a really good case to be made that
taking yourself out of your mind and i'm
gonna
make a pejorative statement about the
vast majority of people who choose to
listen to podcasts and consume this type
of content in any case
i think that'll select for a
particularly cerebral type of person
already i think they'll exist a lot more
in their head than they will in their
body and i certainly know that i do
as someone who thinks that he's trying
to push
these boundaries already so i definitely
agree i think there's a lot that can be
taken from the embodiment practice
yeah you know man should be well danced
and well for as well as well read
and i love reading you know you just
loaded books behind me ordered about
five yesterday i'll probably get around
to reading two of them if i'm lucky
i love reading but we need something
more than that if we're gonna grow as
people we need to practice we need some
way to get back in our bodies and as you
say in these times i think it's
particularly important
we you know we're in this slightly
disembodied world right now and
um yeah i'd encourage people to
whatever body practice appeals to them
give it a go i love it tell us about
your conference
okay so we have a huge conference coming
up uh
where to begin i love embodiment i think
it's a good thing
i'd like to see out in the world i've
been putting stuff out on the online on
youtube
and my podcast and what i'm in for free
and then i went hang on a minute we
could do an online event
two years ago we did it for the first
time everyone laughed at us because no
one knew what zoom was then
15 000 people turned up and then i
thought to myself well hang on how big
can we make this
and now we've got a thousand speakers
probably going to be half a million
people booked in
the embodiment conference it's called
the embodiment conference.org
all the top names in trauma and yoga in
meditation martial arts free to the
world
and we we make our money by buying the
record people buy the recordings but
it's totally free if people want to
listen into it
it's the embodiment conference.org and
um
i'm going to be honest it's a terrifying
proposition all of a sudden i'm the
mayor of a small town
and i mean a million pounds to do it um
and i'm in charge of a team of 60 people
and i'm like you know i'm used to doing
little embodiment trainings for 30 or 50
people so
it's a bit of a step up for me and um
what can i say i feel inspired by it i
feel stressed by it i feel
um uh happy i'm doing it i feel
frustrated sometimes it's
the full spectrum it's it's like a mount
everest to climb
but um it's happening it's really
happening so if people are
at all curious about this stuff the
embodiment conference would be a good
place to
um get a taste get a free taste of many
many different approaches like a kind of
tapas meal you know when is it it is the
40th the 25th of october
it's online it's free for everyone free
to register real easy to do
and uh there's 10 different channels
running simultaneously 24 hours a day
it's in nine languages as well so if
people want to listen to it in german or
spanish or chinese
whatever they can so it's um yeah it's
we think it's the largest
educational event in human history uh
it's certainly the largest online summit
there's ever been
uh it's pretty ambitious in its scope
and we've got this very clever computer
system some israeli friends of mine made
which is sort of
means you can find what you want rather
than just get lost in it
so you can say right i want to learn
about trauma and i want a beginner's
class and i want it next tuesday
and you just put all that in and you can
find what you need
dude what an event man that is uh a
serious a serious undertaking
you know someone told me hey well what
about next year i said i'm not going to
talk about this is crazy like so it's
really something and i
i wanted to push it and just see how far
it would go and um you know have that
personal challenge and
as i said i think this embodiment is
needed in the world today
i think we are disconnected from
ourselves and that has prob that leads
to all sorts of problems whether it be
health problems emotional problems
we're disconnected from each other you
know we're disconnected from the planet
and those those things cannot continue
so even in this weird
techie you know tuning in online
learning embodiment on the internet
world we need to find a way to come home
to the body
and i hope this is um some contribution
towards that
awesome man i think that's a really
noble pursuit and
i'm gonna guess that this was planned
long before covid kicked off yeah yeah
yeah it's
18 months in the morning yet 2020
probably a pretty good year for people
to have this some sense of community a
connection to half a million people
yeah i mean the facebook ad price came
down if nothing else you know but um
it was i mean i'm joking i don't wish
covered on anyone it can be
nasty particularly for elderly people
can't it but um i think a lot of people
isolated stuck indoors
uh having we've done a lot of lead up
events to this we did events on stress
and trauma and you know different things
like that and
you could see it was really beneficial
for people to
even if they were in the house to get
connect with other people
um that feels like a worthwhile thing to
be putting out there and you know giving
some of the
the skills and the experts and just
making it globally available for
everyone online
so um i'm proud of it to be honest mate
i feel like we've already achieved
something just getting to this point
and um yeah it's it's definitely a test
for me as a leader
it's not always easy but um i'm proud
we're doing it
congratulations man people want to check
it out where do they go the embodiment
conference.org or if they just google
embodiment conference uh people like
what i've been hearing and saying here
as well they can look at youtube
channels about it the podcast they've
got a book out called embodiment
basically you start googling the word
embodiment you're going to come up with
all this stuff and there's
loads of free resources online so um
yeah i want to encourage people to look
up those there's lots of other teachers
in this field not just me
and if i'm not your cup of tea you might
like paul linden richard strzecler wendy
palmer there's a
whole load of great teachers out there
in the world i love it everything that
we've gone through will be linked in the
show notes below i'll be tuning in i
think i'll
ask you for your uh your top superstars
from the conference it'll be like asking
you to choose your favorite children or
something
i have to tell you offline yeah i was
going to say i'm going to ask for the
secret
yeah it's a little bit political the
super secret best of guest list and i'm
going to get i'm going to tune in and do
that mark today's been really really fun
man i've really enjoyed it and i think
that
the concepts that we've gone through
hopefully will help a lot of people
like i say anyone that's interested in
finding out a little bit more about this
i'll have linked most of the stuff that
you need or if not just search mark
walsh or
the embodiment conference online and
you'll be able to find out some more for
now
man thank you so much thanks for your
time chris pleasure
you